uh welcome Alexandra uh congratulations
it is always nice to finish the
tournament and uh well on a positive
note indeed but for the moment you're
also on the clear second place well I
have six out of nine I'm sorry but I
have six out of nine I I know that I
could have gotten more or but that's
that's it if there is someone who sticks
out of nine we're gonna talk okay but
yeah of course it's a very very I mean
I'm very happy to finish on a win and to
finish so well because I mean this
tournament as I mentioned it's second in
a row so the fatigue the cold the
disappointment of this like stolen point
I mean and despite all uh like this um
in the background I managed to play well
and to finish well so of course I cannot
complain so tell us more about the game
you played today against uh Elizabeth
Pitts with the black pieces it was a
highly theoretical game yes that was an
anti-martial line and actually I looked
at this line before my game was Jean say
Abdul Malik because she played this line
but with C3 Bishop C2 I don't think it
should be dangerous for uh black because
I mean intuitively white just putting
the bishop on the wrong diagonal it was
there is a line with Bishop A2 which I
consider a little bit more dangerous and
I think I played well I mean so here's
the position yes so it's about equal
it's all about D5 right here D4 and D5
in this Roy Lopez games and I was very
happy when on the 24th move I played D5
and I think I solved all my I mean
problems if there were any uh with this
move and then somehow I don't know what
she did wrong probably E5 was uh wrong
because then it started uh to be very
difficult for white and she was getting
closer to time travel and okay I'm just
you know threatening to take the spawn
so if you inaccurate decisions here led
to a very unpleasant position which is
again it can be holdable by a computer
but it's so unpleasant to play uh in a
practical game on the time pressure and
yeah then she blundered on the 39th move
although I was not happy with my
attempts to win the game in time travel
instead of just capturing the pawn on um
A5 yes here for example Queen takes if I
I played Queen A7 although I see that
the game computer likes it yeah because
here okay she was going to play Queen B5
like capture I'm an exchange actually I
have an extra opponent pair of Bishops
it should be enough to win but you know
it's going to be a long battle and you
want to finish it as soon as possible
but here yeah somehow I thought that
Rook C2 is not going to be possible due
to rookie one but then I realized that
after Knight F1 Bishop A6 that I was
going to play I mean let's do Bishop of
B5 yeah I mean and there is nothing and
I mean I got disappointed
and I uh yeah played a switch to this
back to the plan of just getting a pawn
but she blundered by plane 93 instead
rookie 2 I think was the only way to
play and hear well I was going to play
Bishop A6 to exchange everything to take
the pawn on A5 and okay
again a very pleasant position with an
extra Pawn but you know like you should
really demonstrate your Technique here
and when you're tired it's not so clear
so I was very happy when she played 93
the only problem here was you know to
pick which
after the time travel when she played 96
check
I mean here I have two moves uh King G7
and King H7 I was I was hesitating
because
um like I thought that she was going to
play Bishop B5 anyway on both of them
and I was afraid that after Bishop B5
Queen B5 rookie to Queenie two okay here
I have to take on H6
A6
and it should be winning like D3 Queen
takes these three Bishop D4 but I
thought what if you know during a
practical game you start like hesitating
what if it's not winning who cares that
you have an extra Bishop maybe it's a
fortress and I was so scared and I
played King 27 okay I thought that she
was going to play Bishop B5 anyway
and then yeah same line but here I have
a choice I can also take on A5 Queen
takes A5 and I like this idea very much
but I was afraid also of Queen E8
and then yeah somehow if I play
something like D3 yes D3 well H4 doesn't
work okay I thought that as we will get
closer I would decide whether to whether
to take on A5 or just simply capture on
H6 and play this uh end game with an
extra piece which should be winning but
sometimes you just get scared of those
ghosts you know and yeah but now that we
analyze this with the computer uh you
can see that that's interesting yeah
that was a very clean game indeed uh
Alexandria we had today an interview
with Judith poker and she told us that
um later in the career it is very
difficult to find motivation so do you
still have goals
no not really I mean my like uh
goal so we can my my goal is to play a
good game so like I take it game by game
and tournament by tournament and yes
indeed it's very hard to motivate
yourself not only play tournaments but
also work in between tournaments on
chess and sometimes I'm I'm not very
good in forcing myself to
um like sit and do those daily routine
that you must do unfortunately because
if you don't I'm in work at home then
kind of during tournaments you try to
like close this gap of theoretical
problems and um like you run out of
energy sometimes and make mistakes but
uh
time after time I mean
I'm able to you know to play well and to
produce some nice games it keeps me
going
so how does your perfect day look like
there's no chest in it no no definitely
not
wow so I mean there is some chairs but
you know just not to feel guilty because
if I don't study Chess at all I mean I
have this
unhappy voice inside me like complaining
that aha you didn't study I mean you
should have so no there is some chess
but just a little bit and but definitely
not in a tournament now I'm like I'm so
happy that it's like this classical part
of two tournaments and Rose over and
there is going to be one more very like
new event in Dubai as it starts in less
than a week the global chest leak I
don't know what to expect but at least
it's a rapid event so I can rest from
the classical chess and but another
thing that I want to add what keeps me
going what is my motivation actually
um
such tournaments or my motivation
because it's amazing I mean when I was
starting my chess career you know we
could have only dreamed about such
tournaments with such price funds with
such conditions and it's incredible I
mean I feel so grateful and lucky to be
able to play here like third time in a
row it's already for me it's quite an
achievement and of course I want to
thank the organizers for creating such a
dream come true tournament for women's
chess and that's probably why it's so
it's pity just to stop playing you know
at this point when there are so many
great tournaments and you just want to
play you cannot refuse such invitations
so that definitely keeps me going thank
you Alexander and you are one of the
greatest Fighters I think on the chess
scene yesterday do you have a question
first of all uh just congratulations for
an outstanding result we're forgetting
about the point that was taken away just
an outstanding result but also simply
for being an inspire thank you Alexandra
congrats Alexandra absolutely as
Alexander close to New York in the
clubhouse hoping for a clear second will
Arena Crush managed to